I think he's really started to do some
really important things I think is
meeting with victims during his his
visit to the United States was historic
and really unprecedented I think though
that there's always more that can be
done for the sex abuse crisis in 2002
the US bishops met in Dallas to
formulate their zero tolerance policy
which I think was necessary but I think
that you know the clerical culture that
gave rise to that sex abuse crisis which
is essentially you know a few very sick
men who are moved around from parish to
parish you know by some bishops you know
for fear of quote-unquote causing
scandal that that's more of a cultural
type thing I think that needs to be
addressed so I think what the church
needs to do is to have a culture of much
more transparency and frankly you know
when these guys do these things they
need to be kicked out and in the United
States that's already happened so I
don't think you'll see it in the United
States you might hear reports of ones
that happened you know maybe in the 60s
and 70s but you know going ahead there
is this zero tolerance policy I think
other countries is starting to realize
that now what needs to be done it really
needs to be just sort of taken out root
and branch and blamed on the right
sources it has nothing to do with
celibacy as nothing to do with you know
gay clergy anything like that I'm
neither of those two things lead to
pedophilia it has to do I think with
this culture of secrecy and the
wrongheaded notion that we shouldn't
quote-unquote cause scandal by revealing
some of these things so so i hope the
catholic church really takes the lead in
showing other organizations about this
because you know i mean most sex abuse
takes place in families you know there's
sex abuse in schools or sex abuse and
children's organizations like the Boy
Scouts and Girl Scouts so I think that
the Catholic Church has an opportunity
here to really take the lead and be in
the vanguard of preventing children from
being abused